I've been in jail Danny all my life I
ain't never been a cow ain't never been
a PC and he never worked with the pony
and I ain't never went on the other side
of the field and gave [ __ ] up I walked
my walk but every time I had to do I
served it I didn't cross the line and
give the police no information in order
for me to be a better person in order
for me to be able to walk that walk I
walked it because I had time to do I
don't [ __ ] bread with the officers I
don't do that I know my responsibilities
and I know my obligations I know my
priorities and I know my I know my rules
that I follow and I don't break them for
nobody
if I tell you my word is good that's
where I stand beyond I don't make
promises that I can't keep but I stand
behind everything that I tell you I'm
not a buster I'm not a mark I'm not a
[ __ ] I'm a soldier that stand on the
front line of this [ __ ] and I like I
said again ain't afraid of nothing you
could send your best buddy at me he
could be king kong's son I'll take his
ass home and if he whupped me at least I
know I took him off that's hot stand man
you know I stand in these streets now
and I'm not afraid to walk these streets
and you have to be strong in order to
walk because you see so much [ __ ] goes
on that night you'd be surprised to see
that your heart is still pumping
that's how scary some of the [ __ ] that
you have to live with out here and keep
going
they keep your mother keep your
[ __ ] mouth shut and just go
that's your day be your day and don't
let it be the things that you spilled
out and tell the wrong person because if
you do you might not live to see the
next month so watch what you're saying
certain things you can't say that
certain things you can't say
is the truth dolls
I'm just I'm just burning up right now
you